- Give us Versace, it's right there.
Booked, booked, booked,
well at least for me.
Period, period, period, period.
(techno music)
- [Narrator] We brought
together seven runway models.
- I'm a runway model.
- [Narrator] One of them is a liar.
If the group discovers who the liar is,
they will split a cash prize.
If the liar survives,
they win the entire prize.
Who is the odd one out?
- Is any of us signed here to an agency,
a manager, anything like that?
Okay, cool, for how long?
- It's almost four.
- I was like, am am I runway model?
Am I a model?
These other people are
gorgeous, they're beautiful.
I mean, Ty, I'm pregnant already.
- Did you ever think that
maybe there's more to life
than being really, really,
really ridiculously good looking.
- How tall are we?
- I'm 5'6" and a half.
- I'm 5'10".
- I'm 5'5" and a half.
- Okay.
- I'm 5'9".
- I'm 6 foot.
- 6'2".
- 5'9".
Just wanna' say immediately,
I'm kind of obsessed with both of you,
just for being a little
on the shorter side.
I'm 5'9" and I've been kicked outta' shows
for being too short.
- I think it's a difference
on the runway you do.
If it's like super high
fashion, Milan, New York
sometimes they are much more strict.
- It's catered to everyone these days,
and I'm like, happy that I get to, like
- You got the face, it's not about height.
Like, come on.
- But also, I don't
think it really matters
on the face anymore, nowadays either.
I think it just really relies
on your inner confidence.
What you bring to the table.
I mean you can be pretty, but
also there are many people who
you know, aren't necessarily
pretty to other people.
(bell rings)
(upbeat music)
- She was a little bit shorter,
which doesn't really mean anything,
but for me that was like red flags.
(buzzer sound)
- Good luck, y'all.
(upbeat music)
- That face honey, it's the face honey.
Talk about face is not
important, yes it is.
- Give us the beats, where okay.
Absolutely.
Okay, no.
All opinions canceled, shortie can walk.
- Personally, I think I had the best walk.
- Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Giving us LA models, giving
us Vision Modeling Agency.
Hey boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
- I didn't think my walk was too good.
I definitely let nerves
get the best of me.
- Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom
boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
They're gonna roast me on this song.
Boom, boom, boom.
Okay, okay.
Giving us elegance.
Give us Versace, it's right there.
Booked, booked, booked, at least for me.
Period, period, period, period.
Yes, absolutely.
- Let's talk shows.
What shows have we been in?
- I did like a, it was
called Kornit Fashion Week.
- So did I.
- Oh okay, for sure.
So we're both, we're good.
Yeah, so I did Kornit Fashion
Week beginning of November.
I walked for five
designers, actually four,
'cause I got kicked out
of one of the shows.
- [Sasha] It's not
always about to bookin'.
- No, I'm saying 'cause
I wasn't tall enough,
like literally.
- I'm from Las Vegas, so
we literally have a mall
called Fashion Show Mall,
- Fashion Show Mall,
- So that's where I got my start.
- Yes, same girl.
- And so like I've done like Macy's,
- [Sasha And George] Dillard's
- [Sasha] Nordstrom.
- I wanted to give Sasha the chance.
You might not be a typical runway model,
but you said you do Macy's and Dillard's
and that's kind of like very,
almost like geriatric modeling.
Like anybody can do it.
Like a grandma could walk those runways.
So I was like, cool, that's
runway experience though.
If you guys are ever there,
go check it out, it's cool.
I mean, I didn't really realize
it was like mall modeling
but if it's a mall modeling
gig, it's kind of the best one.
You know what I'm saying?
- I've been on a few
auditions, or castings,
for some runway shows.
My biggest like casting I
was like kind of shocked,
'cause they were like NDA, NDA,
was for Gucci and they were
like, they wanted to see me.
I was just like
- [Sasha] You want to see me?
- Okay!
But like, I mean again, I
probably didn't book it because.
- My first show was in New York in 2017.
- This I believe, you can stop
talking we all believe you.
- And the last show I walked was, well
I guess I did Kornit
Fashion Week as well too.
But the real, my like last like big one,
was I walked for Kappa in Milan.
- Also I believe it.
- We have to talk, I'm
going to Milan soon.
- Do you guys think
that this would be
based on a technicality,
'cause we all seem like we
have some runway experience.
- I mean not to be a bit bold,
but I think Aissa's suss.
- Me?
- [Ty] Yeah.
- I was gonna say the same thing.
I feel bad, just it's the height for me.
I just like, since I've been
kicked out and I'm like 5'9",
your walk is incredible though.
Like, insane.
- Regardless she needs to be booked.
(bell rings)
- Her story seemed a bit choppy
and it kind of was a bit back and forth.
- Yes there are opportunities
for shorter runway models,
but I don't think that
there is many opportunities
and I don't think that
it's a standard yet.
- Like anyone can practice a
walk and make it look good.
To be 5'5" and do runways,
definitely challenging.
(dramatic music)
(buzzer sound)
- I love you, girl.
- [Narrator] Please raise your hand
if you want to continue playing the game.
- Yeah, that's what I'm talking about.
- [Narrator] Starting now,
for every time all of
you vote out someone,
who's not the mole, the total
prize money will be reduced.
- I mean, I only wanted to keep playing
because I wanted to keep playing.
I think we found the,
- Look at you now we're
getting deducted because.
- I know I didn't, I didn't
see that second part.
- Like I found it really
like hard in this industry
'cause I feel like they still have
very like white beauty standards.
And like, there's just like the bringing
your own makeup to set.
Like I never come with my hair natural
'cause I'm always afraid that
they know what to do with it.
- And I've had such a
different like juxtaposition
now that I kind of have made the decision
for myself that I was
going to show up as myself.
And so the natural hair
is just non-negotiable.
I do think that there's a
lot of other perspectives
that we also aren't seeing
when it comes to runway.
I think runway is the most
traditional that's like holding
on to all of its old ways.
Like the skinny, it's like it's
literally catching up last.
So I don't know.
Who else would you guys
think that the mole is,
since everybody else
chose to keep playing?
I did not.
- I forget, who's signed?
- I'm signed to an agency.
- Who are you with, everyone?
- I'm with InFocus Modeling.
- With LA models.
- Okay.
- I'm with Nomad Management,
Ferrari Talents and Commercial,
and then I have a mother
agent in New York.
- Coco Rocha,
- I'm with Ferrari, too.
- Nomad, with Nomad?
- Yes! Did that 'cause she can walk.
- [Sasha] I did model camp too!
- It really doesn't matter
as long as you get to
the casting, you guys.
- Yeah, really.
- Any worst experiences,
any like bad experiences
that you like wanna share?
- At first when I started doing
runway, I didn't, I hated it
because we all know like the
pay is not good for runway.
When I was in Thailand, like my Uber
to get to the casting,
and then to get home,
and then to get to the show
was more than I was making for the show.
- I struggled a lot with just like,
feeling beautiful and like
trying to like project,
like I have a loved
one who's incarcerated,
so it's been kind of one of those things
where they can only get pictures.
So I've been kind able
to share like my journey.
- My journey, my whole life, literally.
- 'Cause that's all they can get.
So it's been kind of like,
that's what kind of keeps me going.
It's like, why do you put
yourself through this?
Well, it's like that,
- I'm documenting my life literally.
And so I think that there's no other mole
I'm gonna' be real.
I've said that this whole
round, but you know.
- I just wanted to keep
playing and I kind of started,
- A little competitive.
(bell rings)
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator] We counted all
the votes and we have a tie.
Dakota and Sasha, each
of you has 20 seconds
to state your case.
- So for, like I said, I'm from Vegas,
so Fashion Show Mall is
where I got my start.
I love modeling, I love runway.
Even though it challenges me.
It's that connection.
It's that, you know,
being able to share it
with a loved one that
really drives it for me.
- I've been modeling for
four years since I was 16.
I have done a lot of
traveling for modeling.
I've been to Beijing, Thailand,
I've met with agencies in
Tokyo, I've been to New York,
I've been Mexico City, here, obviously,
I've met with agencies in Miami.
I've like, I've been in this
industry for a long time.
(dramatic music)
(buzzer sound)
- And that is my secret,
please do not tell anyone.
- [Woman Off Camera] Psst.
Jason, we're rolling.
- Oh right now?
Oh, I'm sorry, I didn't have my glasses on
which coincidentally are from
Warby Parker, today's sponsor.
Warby Parker is committed
to providing exceptional vision
care online and in stores.
Offering eyeglasses,
sunglasses, eye exams,
and contact lenses.
What is special about Warby Parker
is just how easy it is to find
the right pair of glasses.
After answering just a
few questions online,
Warby Parker will actually suggest glasses
that fit your face and your style.
Try Warby Parker's free
home try on program.
Order five pairs of glasses to try at home
for free for five days.
There's no obligation to buy it.
It ships for free
and includes a prepaid
return shipping labeling.
For every pair of glasses sold,
Warby Parker actually distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need.
Again, try five pairs of
glasses at home for free,
at warbyparker.com/jubilee.
Now enjoy the video.
- [Narrator] Raise your hand
if you want to continue playing the game.
If the lights turn green
that means you have voted the mole out.
If the lights turn red
that means the mole is still
in the box and you lose.
Now can the mole please step forward
and reveal themselves in 3, 2, 1.
- I knew it, y'all
shouldn't have voted for me.
- Sasha was like the tallest
one there and she was great,
and she had a great walk,
and she looks awesome.
So she would've been either my last
or my second to last pick.
- I think my height saved me honestly.
There is that still, like,
the preconceived notion of
what a model looks like.
And I think that this
episode really emphasizes
that we do have a long way to go.
- I definitely believe
that she could model
but the walk was a little off for me.
- I didn't believe that you were the mole,
solely because I actually
believe in people.
So to, I think conflate the,
like doing it because of your
loved one that's incarcerated
is extremely offensive.
And so that was something
that I just wouldn't have
stooped as low as to do.
And so that's, wow.
- I do really have a loved
one who's incarcerated.
I don't do runway, but like I,
and I'm sorry that you felt that way.
'Cause I didn't think like
that, 'cause it was like
in my mind that's still
so true to my story
and like of who I am.
And like I do send photos
to my dad, you know,
and keep him up to date.
I just have never been on a runway.
- That's not her story,
it's her father's story.
And so the way that we share
about incarcerated people
has to be considered.
- I do take photos.
I love doing photo shoots.
I've never been paid for a gig before.
Like I kind of just do
it because I find it fun.
And I found that as I take photos,
like I'm able to share
them with my loved one.
And it's been kind of like
our fun way of communicating,
you know?
And he's getting a glimpse
of the outside world
and he's seeing what I'm working on.
So like that is very true
and it wasn't like a made-up story at all.
The only thing was, is just I'm
not a runway model, I guess.
- [Narrator] How does it feel to win?
- It feels great.
I'm still in shock, honestly.
- What's the most common
questions someone asks you
when they learn you're a triplet?
- [Dark Haired Triplets] Dick size.
- Are you serious?
- [Dark Haired Triplets] All the time.
- We are triplets.
- We are triplets
- I feel bad now, though.
Like I feel so bad.
(techno music)